[Music]  [Applause]  your first time meeting yellow kid it  was everything I wanted it to be he's a  he's a comedian and an artist at the  same time he's great superstar  what does it been like to literally  become almost an overnight celebrity  that I  I don't know yeah I really had zero up  like that this was going to happen but I  would still be singing in Walmart for 50  more times and then  and what happened but this this just  came right out of the blue just like  that yeah have you since gone back to  Walmart and saying since you sort of  became this overnight sensation in  Walmart what was it like to meet Justin  Bieber to know that he was such a fan of  yours well he's mostly a pop singer but  he's cool anyways so some people think  that you know they they like people  flattered country but I'm different I  like everybody let me give you any  advice  yes  keep singing  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]